[Music]
what is conscious well I mean there's
certain fast question the code I think
consciousness is the realm of
possibility and you can't know about
possibilities unless they're in a
conscious space
I think Minds are containers of
possibility possibilities are not
physical facts they're just
possibilities and they can only exist in
something like an imagination so I think
our conscious mind so you know that's
what they do they're to do with choices
among possibilities our unconscious
minds are about habits things that we
just do automatically we don't need to
think about them and I think all minds
really are spaces of possibility even
the mind underlying the cosmos so I
think that think of Minds in general as
conscious spaces or realms or containers
of possibility units on the road there -
oh I'm propensity ISM I just think those
pentakus don't go far enough
oh those Penn psychos talk about the
consciousness or minds of electrons or
protons or and assumes and things like
that which is fine the reason they do
that is because they're trying to
explain how we come to be conscious
standard materialism is the doctrine
that matters unconscious the whole
universe is unconscious and then they
have the problem okay everything's
unconscious and everything's made of
matter including our brains how come
we're conscious so they only have to say
well the consciousness somehow emerges
out of complex arrangements but how can
something totally different from
unconscious matter emerge that's called
the hard problem in the philosophy of
mind so to get out of that some pants
cyclists some materialists have become
pants cyclists by saying okay well let's
have a little bit of consciousness in
electrons and atoms and things so
consciousness can emerge from something
that has a much much lower
of mind or consciousness even in
subatomic particles and therefore we can
overcome the problem of how something
different in that it's a difference of
degree not a difference in kind the
emergence of consciousness in human
brains so I think that's fine I don't
have a problem with that but the
question I then asked them is well what
about the Sun the Sun is a
self-organizing system what does the Sun
think about what's the mind of the Sun
like I'm personally I think the sun's
conscious and indeed the entire galaxy
and the whole universe so I'm in favor
of pan psychism but pan means everywhere
psyche means mind I'm in favor of pen
sarcasm I just think it's so much too
limiting to confine it to the realm of
subatomic physics so this is not an
emergent property of well emergent
property I mean what does it mean it
means that something comes from
something that wasn't there before it's
a way of conjuring something out of like
a rabbit out of a hat you see there are
three main ways of thinking about it one
is top-down the whole universe is
conscious and even before there was any
matter there was consciousness or mind
and the evolution of matter in the
universe is the the universe has lower
and lower levels of consciousness as it
evolves the Big Bang the entire universe
is one system one mind as it were then
the fields of physics and things
separate art and stars and galaxies and
whatnot so then you have the emergence
of many forms of consciousness and then
on life a life on Earth you have they I
dare say in biology there is an
emergence of higher forms of
consciousness I mean we have more than a
worm or a bacterium so in that area in
then you could say that there is a kind
of emergence but the top-down
consciousness means you start with
consciousness and it goes down from the
bar as it were the bottom-up materialist
theory is you start from subatomic
particles and atoms
and you work your way up and then you
have said well it emerges but you could
just as well say it descends the third
position is say well it's both there's a
sense in which there's a an emergency or
an appearance of high levels of
complexity with more complexity but it's
not that it was not there before and
after all our evolution has happened
within on the planet Earth within a
galaxy and what if the whole galaxy and
what if the whole solar system are
conscious and what if Gaia the earth is
conscious then our consciousness has
appeared within much larger conscious
systems so you know these are
philosophically different ways of
looking at it there's a prejudice in
modern science in favor of materialism
and reductionism and bottom-up
explanations but that's really a kind of
philosophical fashion it's not the truth
well it's been the fashion since the
late 19th century's science became
dominated by materialism in the late
19th century and in many ways our views
of matter have changed since then they
had an old classical physics view of
matters little atoms as little billiard
balls quantum theory changes that very
radically and they didn't know about the
galaxies beyond our own or the Big Bang
or modern cosmology so all these things
have changed but the philosophy of
materialism swatted locked in a 19th
century worldview and of course you can
have an updated materialism and in a
sense pants cyclists are trying to
update materialism but as soon as you
admit psyche or mind into matter then
it's not really materialism it's really
a form of animism animism is the belief
that whole of nature is alive and they
hold universes like an organism not a
machine I think that's a much more
reasonable view of myself so what we're
at the moment in is a kind of conflict
between old-style materialism and the
kind of animism Orpen psychism
struggling to get out and so far it's
only got as far as atoms and molecules
but one reason I like to ask pentakus
about the consciousness of the song is
that I think they're on a slippery slope
and I'd like to push them down it a bit
fast and they go on their own and
discussing the consciousness of the Sun
is a very good way of accelerating this
slide down the slippery slope into a
full-blown animism it seems to me like
there's a what was what was the basic
definition of consciousness then what is
this thing that the materialists and
well I mean there's hundreds of
definitions but it's to do with
awareness and as I said to start with
possibility I that's my own definition
it's about a realm of possibility they
would say it's about perception
awareness algorithms in the brain you
know as soon as you get into modern
cognitive neuroscience then the brain is
a computer consciousness is just the
software programs running it but they of
course needn't be conscious in fact
they're not conscious so in the
materialist philosophy of mind
consciousness is either an epiphenomenon
that does nothing like a kind of shadow
of physical activity in the brain that
has no role and has no free well it
doesn't actually do anything that's the
majority of you or else it's an illusion
produced by brains because it might have
some conceivable evolutionary advantage
but it still doesn't do anything the
problem is that to call consciousness an
illusion doesn't explain it it
presupposes it because illusion is
itself a made of consciousness so
philosophers of mind and the materialist
school go round and round in circles
like dogs chasing their tails trying to
explain it never succeed and any one of
them comes up with a theory another one
will point out the flaws and they come
up with their own and the other one will
point out the flaws in it and that's why
it's called the very existence of
consciousness is called the hard problem
it seems to me one major part of that is
just the limit
of language of word to adequately
describe a phenomena the way I think
this the heart problem is will show many
things one of it is just how limited
English or languages to describe them
stuff I don't think the problem the
consciousness is a problem at language I
mean language itself of course is a
product of consciousness and languages
inadequate to explain many things
including the ultimate nature of reality
at the beginning of the universe and so
forth but I don't think that the problem
is with language I think the problem is
with worldviews and do you have a
worldview that's essentially an atheist
materialist worldview
there is no God there is no
consciousness out there the universe is
unconscious it's purposeless meaningless
everything's happened by chance or
accident the laws of nature have no
particular reason to be one way or the
other we just live in a universe where
they happen to be right for us
evolution is a matter of blind chance
mutations and blind natural selection
that's a worldview that says that
consciousness has just emerged in our
brains and doesn't actually do anything
also that we don't have free will
a deeply depressing worldview and I
think that when you have whole societies
based on it like ours what you'd predict
is that lots of people would suffer from
depression and the facts actually bear
that out if you think you live in a
meaningless world where your mind is
just in your brain and it's nothing more
than what's happening inside your head
not truly related to anything else
deeply depressing whereas if you think
that consciousness is primary that we
live in a universe that's purposeful
that our minds are part of something
much greater than ourselves that
mystical experiences connect us with
greater Minds than our own they're not
just serotonin levels changing inside
our brains then you have a completely
different view of the universe it's not
just a matter of language
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you